and one of my favorite books as a kid
was Fahrenheit 451 and this is Ray
Bradbury's classic book from the 1950s
and you know I don't think it's possible
to spoiler a book that's that all the
it's okay you've been talking recently
about the matrix a lot on your show and
you're like I don't even have to say
spoiler because you haven't seen in 20
years you're here it's not gonna be a
spoiler for you but but that book for
our natural 51 is a dystopian novel that
Ray wrote in the context of the McCarthy
era book burnings that were going on and
I wonder if you see that coming from
these little black mirrors that we all
have does that now kind of manifest
itself in a completely different way
decentralized you know to spread out and
and how a society interacts with it to
effectively not burn but cancel this
book like don't cancel this book that's
a great question and there's so much
there and I'm a big sci-fi guy too and
so much of the way I view the world is
because I don't want us to end in a
dystopian future I don't want the
machines to take over from terminator I
don't want to have to end up living on
Mars like Total Recall or being the
battery like in the matrix or or or you
know one of the beautiful things about
Fahrenheit 451 is that many of the
people that were doing the burning were
secretly having thoughts that were free
thoughts that's right and in many ways
that caused them to do more burning
because they had to hide their you know
I mean this is there's a very religious
sort of repress yourself and then
destroy the other sort of notion in that
I would say I'm very you know it's funny
I describe myself as a world weary
optimist
[Music]